this is exciting for me uh I'm joined by
Rock royalty Gene Simmons from Kiss how
are you how are you young man it's good
to have you here thank you in the UK in
London in my studio in your studio we go
back a long way we do we did Celebrity
Apprentice what I knew it 2008 and just
to remind anyone left in the world I
haven't told which one of us won go on I
do yes yes he did but only because you
quit early and if you had you'd have
beaten me well that's not so but you're
you're very bright and good looking
it's signaling that it may be the end no
it is it is you've got to have you know
at some point we're all grown-ups we've
got to be able to understand when the
curtain comes down everything's got to
come to an end at some point have a
little dignity and self-respect love
your fans and understand when it's time
to graciously thank them for an amazing
journey that's lasted could you really
walk away from the states yes really
because the alternative is staying on
the stage too long the way who's who has
gone on too long in your estimation oh
many many perhaps you want me to name
and shame
who have you looked at hang on come on
it's time it's not fair you could look
you can you can see them by the number
of creases on their face and so on
Rock basically is a young man's
generally speaking uh form of music and
look half a century is plenty of time to
put on more makeup and wear higher heels
than your girlfriend we've done this a
long time December the second is going
to be the last time and we we would love
to see those few tickets remaining if
there are any yeah some of our friends
uh in London at the O2 yeah it's going
to be the last time we will ever play
really that's it yeah we want to play
indoors instead of usually we headline
download or used to be called Monsters
of Rock uh we wanted a more sort of uh
emotional thing because it is what's
been for you I mean if I could let you
relive one moment of your entire rock
career right now which one would you
choose
I would choose the beginning the very
first time we ever got up on stage
fourth on the build New Year's Eve 1973
in New York City
my heart was pumping like uh nothing you
ever saw because you have to understand
when you come from the loins of the
people you know sort of come up on the
streets and you you see these sort of
god-like figures on stage having the
time of their lives being adored there's
no other plumbers don't get that even
the pope doesn't get knickers thrown in
his face
he might but I'm gonna get in trouble
um but this astonishing lifestyle and I
was never the best looking guy and all
that stuff but soon as you start
strumming the guitar and of course
sticking out my prodigious oral
appendage how is the tongue oh it's very
can we have a great flash I would but
the floor is dirty
thank you for that thank you as being a
rock star as it lived up to everything
you hoped it would be it's more than
that it's just so many people moan about
their life in so business oh it's so
you've never you've never moaned about
he thinks they protest too much yeah of
your famous writers said that it's
nonsense how would you like to be have
more money than you know what to do with
have more adoration oh I forgot you're
Pierce more you get that everything
thank you Gene
uh I want to talk about someone else is
in town Roger Waters Pink Floyd you're
uh obviously Jewish he's been coming out
with us Israeli and Israeli and he's
becoming a lot of very anti-israel uh
and what people perceive to be
anti-semitic comments I'm not sure
that's the same thing right so what's
your position about Roger Waters well
first of all he's a very talented guy
he's written some of the most wonderful
music along with Floyd
um many many decades and it's obviously
held up and he's got lots of fans
there is something to be said for
keeping your political and other beliefs
off the stage his choice is to use the
stage as a platform to further his point
of view there is a difference between a
political statement about Israel and
about anti-Semitism by the way
anti-Semitism also involves Arabs the
the definition of a Semite includes the
Arab world so I think is a well-meaning
guy I don't agree with his point of
views of course so do you think he's
anti-semitic or do you think he's
anti-israel I think he is from my point
of view
inflamed angry about the political
situation as we all are you want there
to be peace someplace and look I turn my
our attention to this wonderful fairy
tale of a country uh or their
leprechauns and so on Ireland the North
and the South yes it's been ongoing for
God knows how long and the divisions are
deep if you're either Protestant or
Kathleen or different and I've visited
uh Parliament there we're going to come
to that she offers a break I just want
to play a little clip this is Roger
Waters today he popped up doing some
interview and he said this
my story is yet another story of cancer
culture why are they trying to cancel
Roger Waters why aren't the real
journalists going hang on a minute this
is maybe I'll call up and see what he
has to say why aren't you Piers Morgan
hey
well you know the truth is Roger we have
for the last two years at Piers Morgan
says well actually about 18 months six
months before we came on air and since
we've been on air we have repeatedly
asked you these are all the stuff that
we're showing on screen now all the
requests and back came the response
saying no not available can't do it too
busy on stage off stage so Roger you
need to talk to your people because
you've had a standing offer to come on
Piers Morgan uncensored the entire time
we've been on air look I'd like to jump
in just for a quick second the best way
to have a discussion or even an argument
is find Common Ground yeah and then and
then get into the diversions of what you
think so what we agree with and I'm
Israeli and Jewish my mother was in a
concentration camp in Nazi Germany and
so on and so forth I'm not saying this
to get your your
hard burping anyway we we agree there
absolutely should be an Arab State
Palestine no question about it it should
exist side by side with Israel no
question about it there should be free
flow of information and commerce and so
on
okay so it doesn't exist now let's work
together to try to make it happen so
what's the problem
if only it were that easy Gene but you
know as always you I've got clarity
about these things that's why I like you
let's